good afternoon I'm delighted to be here
today I know you've heard a lot about
what we're doing in Google cloud on the
sales side on the product side and some
about our go-to-market channels I'm
really excited to talk to you today
about what we've been doing and what
we're in the process of really building
and our tech partners organization this
organization came together just a few
months ago to really focus on our tech
partners ecosystem and by that we mean
you know independent software vendors
and also our top strategic partners
we've been scaling this operation in
fact it's you know as Diane mentioned
earlier sometimes the rate of the
scaling is kind of dizzying but I want
you to understand what our philosophy
for that and so hopefully we can partner
with you and and and many of your
customers about how we take take this
ecosystem forward so when we first
started thinking about what it means to
partner we started thinking about our
principles and and I want to run you
through those but then I want to tell
you how we operationalize them and how I
think that's really quite different and
how it's going to make an even bigger
difference in and what we build together
first of all we want to be the open
platform and the open partner and you've
heard that a lot from Brian students
this morning about how open we are with
respect to like things like open source
but in this case the openness extends
even further than that and I'll talk
about a couple of examples where that
openness really changes the way our
partnering is put together we also want
to bring more innovation than just
Google could bring by itself and that's
really one of the tenants that Diane
laid out early on about our partnering
is that we really want to have a you
know a much bigger innovation story than
than any one company even you know a
company of Google size could build in
building that with our partners is
something that really excites you know
our engineers and particularly as we
take it into new applications and new
markets you know fairness and
transparency are really core tenants of
Google and that fairness and
transparency when extended to partners I
think gives us a real strong competitive
advantage in that people want to partner
with Google because we're going to be
fair and transparent and bring
innovation to a bigger market and all of
that results in a shared
success and and diana said it very often
that that our success and our is really
our partners success if our partners are
not successful you know then it's it's
really just academic what we're doing
and so we've really been focusing a lot
on not just the technical and the
integration parts of how we work with
our partners but what are the business
models how do we make sure that they're
successful how do we split that value of
that we create in the world in a fair
and appropriate way so that we can
sustain you know more and more of this
so just today you know some of this I
know seems kind of uncontroversial like
you know who would vote against these
things but we really start to
operationalize that some really cool
things happen like we've been we look
very early on it's some of the thinking
that you know very typical stuff that
goes on with you know let's say we've
got a new idea out there in the world
should I build or should I partner and
that build or partner you know can
really be a kind of long and painful
thought you know like should I don't
know maybe I should build maybe I should
partner and what we decided was this is
really the wrong way to think about it
if if you're really the open partner in
the open platform you should do both or
you should be open to doing both you
know that we should build and partner
and that's been a really liberating
concept for us not just in terms of what
we're able to do with partners but also
our internal product teams you know they
understand they don't have to build
every single feature everybody thought
of you know we can wind up doing things
where we cover much more of the
innovation and market space by doing
both so recently we've had two really
exciting examples of that both of you
heard some this morning about from
Evernote and also a deal we just did
with box these are very clear examples
of this strategy where we you know
Google has products in each of these
spaces but there's a very big world out
there and a huge number of customers who
prefer box and who prefer Evernote for
their needs and when we partner together
we create a much bigger ecosystem and so
each of them has been using different
points of what Google has to offer in
terms of products and technology you
know from G suite to cloud to
springboard search and assist and also
all of our machine learning techniques
and so you know if you think about this
model for how we even though Google may
now
may in the future have a product in a
certain space it's still a wide-open
feel for how we can innovate together
just as exciting for that is how not
just the things in Google cloud that we
bring but if you think about the entire
portfolio of what Google has to offer in
products and technologies one of the
best things that I found in the sort of
three short months we've been doing this
new Organization for tech partners has
been that you know our friends and other
parts of Google like in Adwords and
analytics and play in YouTube I mean
they're super excited about us being
able to partner with other companies to
really bring what is the power of one
Google to those markets and and really
to innovate in not just technology but
in the way the business is put together
to transform industries and that's
something that you know my organization
is just on fire with how exciting it is
to be able to work on these things with
our partners I'm blessed with a great
number of members of my team who are
both engineers and MBAs and
businesspeople and BD folks and just
putting that all together in a way that
basically moves the needle forward
certainly for us and for our partners
has just been tremendously exciting you
know we we look at different ISVs by a
bunch of different sectors you know and
so there's you know there's all kinds of
ways to inter gauge with Google about in
our organization about how you go about
partnering and so that's we have experts
in each of these areas for you know if
you're in data analytics in the cloud or
if you're in visualization you know we
have a lot of different programs for
each of those and so it's been a really
exciting time to put that together and
start to really take that out to market
and you're starting to see deals that
we're announcing and of course we're
working on a lot more the only thing
that we're doing is we're investing in
the infrastructure for our partners and
the acquisition that we did recently of
our Bottari which is an e-commerce cloud
platform Multi cloud back-end they
provide really nice intelligent test
drives and in one of the more elegant
billing systems that I've seen certainly
on the on the cloud platforms you know
for being able to handle all the major
public clouds I mean the orbit era
platform allows our ice bees to plug
into that and then make really
simplifies their ability
to deploy and have their customers use
you know any of the clouds and this is
something that you know we want to lower
that friction for our partner so that
they can get especially the ISVs can get
to market faster and be able to deliver
you know their services and grow their
businesses better the other thing you
heard earlier today was the acquisition
of Apogee one of the things that I
really enjoy about thinking through how
this is going to affect our partners is
that you know if you use it one of
Apogee so I think really illustrative
examples of one of their customers
Walgreens you can see how you know this
kind of framework can help us move
partnering and the integration of
applications forward much faster this
example shows Walgreens that may have
started with the idea of oh hey look I
can do a photo prints API wouldn't that
be great you know because now we can
just print photos you know with an API
call and over time they grew to say well
you know and I not only do I need to
print photos and and be able to do just
that with an API what about my
prescriptions you know I can you I can
have folks be able to refill their
prescriptions of an API and I can do my
rewards program that way and before you
know it when they especially when they
announced this to the outside world all
of a sudden you have you know imager and
Instagram trying to print photos and you
have WebMD hooked up to their
prescriptions api's and and that
framework for being able to integrate
now hundreds of api's quickly and
securely and be able to make sure that
there's not any kind of falling over as
you try to scale is what I think allows
us to have a framework that our partners
can really build some exciting
applications you know in a way that
really gets them to market quickly and
allows us to put things together that
might have been too hard to do in other
ways so I'm very excited about both of
these acquisitions because they allow
our partners to be a lot more successful
quicker and that's the thing that we
want to use going forward as we try to
build even deeper protect partnerships
so the message of the story today is
that you know we've we've really been
taking a different view to partnering
certainly than Google's had available in
and around cloud we took several groups
and put them together in terms of groups
that we're already doing some partnering
gave them a much bigger scope a much
bigger mission and tripled the size of
the group and we are really on fire with
how
we want to go about doing things that
really make a difference and so you know
if you think about partnering with
Google particularly on the tech
partnering side I can tell you for sure
now is the time that you should really
be doing that investigation with us
because it just seems like there's so
many things to be going at here in terms
of really bringing innovation to our
customers and really transforming
industry so you know we are open for
business and we would certainly love to
talk to folks about how to how to do
more tech partnering thank you for your